[Music]
you are all here on a very special night
because this is the halloween episode
that means it's gonna be spooky that
means it's gonna be scary and that means
when you leave here and tell your
friends i just went to a taping of the
amber ruffin show they're gonna say the
amber ruffin show burned down 10 years
ago
do you guys think you can handle that
yay
okay great but first it's been a crazy
week in america let's find out what
happened
the supreme court last week ruled in
favor of texas's six-week abortion ban
said a woman who was six weeks pregnant
i'm pregnant
the treasury department has created a
new position to oversee racial equity
said the person in that position uh i
got bad news about all the people on
money
that's not a good one this guy is not
good that guy is the worst
according to a new study some of the
natural gas leaking into boston skies
could be coming from inside homes which
isn't shocking when you remember what
they're famous for
you came in here thinking you were one
type of person and you'll leave knowing
you laughed at that
we're all learning about ourselves
unpleasant way that's what halloween is
all about what it's all about
in an attempt to distance themselves
from their negative public image
facebook announced yesterday
you know what i don't want to do this
joke
we'll talk about we all talk about
facebook a little too much these days am
i right
right okay yeah great i'm just gonna
ignore that headline okay and it'll go
away
according to a new study um
amber
don't look but that story is right
behind you
[Applause]
please i don't want to tell that joke
i have a different one that you'll love
here goes
national savings day was this week but
most people didn't celebrate because
there wasn't a lot of interest
amber watch out
[Music]
look at me out of here open up hey wait
wait what about this joke instead
according to a new report families with
one baby spend 75 dollars a month on
diapers that's some expensive [ __ ]
i don't think that one worked you think
okay okay i'll tell it i'll tell it i'll
do it
in an attempt to distance themselves
from their negative public image
facebook announced yesterday that
they're changing their name so be sure
to check out new face who dis book
thank you
major league baseball is making efforts
to reconnect the sport to black
americans they can start by not giving
white people so many dang bets
all those bats
oh that's the wrong kind of bats
you guys
so today is just a mess
and we are in this together as a family
supporters of unvaccinated nba player
kyrie irving held a protest on sunday
they said they would go to the ends of
the earth to support him but they're
afraid they might fall off
yeah
it's so dark
i don't see a curve so you cast a shadow
what do you i can't see a curve there is
a sh what do you think you see when you
see the moon i see a curvy thing but
what i am on is still quite flat
france will return 26 artifacts to benin
africa that it looted in 1892 the return
will be overseen by this guy
i love him
and finally employees at fast food chain
mcdonald's went on strike this week to
protest sexual harassment inside stores
turns out the hamburglar was also
grabbing buns
and that was the monologue did you guys
like it
[Applause]
i like where your standards are
folks
halloween is only two days away and i'm
working hard to find a costume that
encompasses my nerdy side while also
being black as hell
now in case you're like me and that is
something you also want i came up with a
list of options like
aj and freesia
this costume combines two after school
staples 106th and park and dragon ball z
into one beautiful blurty couples
costume
okay
how about this one frankenstein beverly
and mays
um
the lead singer of mays may not let you
go
there's like eight of us in here having
the time of our lives
it's for eight of us
you make me happy
harry potter and the black messiah
wingardium leviosa the revolution my
wizard
how about this one earth wind and fire
water heart
we're the planeteers and you can be one
too because dancing in september is the
thing to do
how about this one dungeons and dragons
who doesn't want to be a level 10 dwarf
paladin with fresh waves
throw them dice
jesse jackson pollock
no i am a mural the morals of the
immoral do not dictate my morale amen
there's also salt and peppa pig
kid in playstation
bernie imac
my little pony by genuine
and last but not least madame cj walker
texas ranger a texas cop that'll set you
straight along with those edges so
head down to your local halloween store
and ask for one of these costumes so
they can say
how to hear your blurred ass blurred
in other news oh that was hard to do
oh i would watch that show so hard
i mean every last one of those shows i
watched the butt off of yes this is just
a the venn diagram of this is so tiny
and if you're in here with me bliss you
yes
republican representative marjorie
taylor green was in the news again this
week but this time it wasn't for
shouting at representative alexandria
ocasio-cortez through the mail slot of
her office store remember that we do
alexandria ocasio-cortez i'm an american
citizen i pay your salary through the
taxes that you collect from me through
the irs you need to get rid of your
diaper and come out and be able to talk
to the american citizens instead of just
having to use a flap
very chill
now this time marjorie taylor green is
in hot water after a video emerged
showing her leaving the white house in
late december 2020 the video seems to
contradict her claims that she had
nothing to do with planning the january
6th attack on the capitol check it out
just finished with our meetings here at
the white house this afternoon we got
had a great planning session for our
january 6 objection we aren't going to
let this election be stolen by joe biden
and the democrats president trump won by
a landslide
well
that seems pretty cut and dry amber
amber roofing god damn it what is it
marjorie taylor green is at the door
trick or treat smell my feet give me
something dumb to tweet
marjorie taylor green you get away from
my door you can't make me it's halloween
the only night of the year where i can
legally shout through mail slots
oh so you're in costume right now what
are you dressed up as a functioning
adult person
what are you dressed as a snowflake
marjorie you are being very scary well
mission accomplished now give me some
candy corn
candy corn who would ever ask for candy
corn someone who doesn't understand the
difference between good and bad
don't let me in there amber elephant no
way oh please please there's a bunch of
tiny socialists out here
how can you tell that they're socialists
cause they're asking for handouts those
are trick-or-treaters help help there's
a tiny iron man coming this way and i
think he wants universal healthcare
marjorie be honest did you help plan the
january 6th riots no comment
when the protesters stormed the capitol
did you high-five them no comment
can you answer any questions about the
insurrection
let me check with my lawyers
sinned
oh
well what did they say
they said lose this number okay
marjorie don't you have work to do
not really at this point shouting awful
things at people is pretty much my
full-time job so you have nowhere else
to be that's right i guess i'll just
have to stay here forever
oh no sorry marjorie not happening
i'm on it
[Applause]
[Music]
you